parents are calling out a washington
state school district after it
distributed these ankle monitors for
student athletes to wear during practice
as part of its efforts to trace covet
19. the superintendent says the monitors
are for both staff coaches and students
on the field so that we can more tightly
determine who might need to quarantine
let's bring in outkick founder clay
travis hey clay
hey how are you ainslie doing well do
you think this is extreme a lot of the
parents are furious they've said okay
we're not going to do it anymore until
the the school board meeting tonight
we'll revisit it and hear from the
parents
yeah i think it's insane
this is furtherance of what has become
effectively a police-covid state around
schools and doesn't make any sense if
you look at what's going on with the
trend lines and you look at the data
england's about to send all of its kids
back to school they're not requiring
mass on any school children because
there's no science to support it yet
here in america most of our kids are
having to wear masks and now we're
starting to put them on ankle monitors
while they play sports this is pure
madness there's nothing to justify it
parents should be justifiably upset
hopefully they'll rectify this absurdity
i know when you hear of ankle monitors
you think of prisoners
and they're putting on students okay
what's clicking on out on out kick
well we've got the milk crate challenge
which is absolutely wild remember we go
on the out kick bus tour next week
college football
effectively back lsu making a bad
decision in my opinion to require either
vaccine passports or negative tests lsu
football fans are fired up in a negative
way over that decision we're covering
all of it encourage people to check out
outkick.com for the latest i'm watching
this video of that guy standing on the
milk craig does he fall oh it's amazing
oh my gosh are they getting injured
oh yes yes
that's one of the attractions is you
have no idea when people are going to go
down and the other question is where are
all the milk crates coming from how do
people have like 40 milk crates to stack
up
that is pretty crazy in and of itself
this guy is going to get you guys need
to do one outside oh my god it's great
weather in new york you guys need to try
it out that reminds me remember the nfl
games last year and people were jumping
off cars and landing on tables
after too much oh yeah that's the bill's
mafia that is their expertise the bills
fans breaking all the tables and
everything else i imagine there'll be
some of this at tailgates and nfl
stadiums this fall for sure sure
all right stay safe everyone thanks clay
for more you can head to outkick.com hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now